hello everyone i'm dana perino along
with dan bond Gino Marie harf Jesse
Watters and Greg Gutfeld it's five
o'clock in New York City and this is the
five
this is a Fox News Alert a must-see TV
moment set for tomorrow in Washington
attorney general bill Barr and the
Deputy Attorney General rod Rosenstein
will hold a news conference at 9:30 a.m.
on the dot on the molar report President
Trump saying he may also do the same
having a press conference bar has been
facing increased scrutiny from Democrats
over his handling of the Russian
investigation so this Dan is a moment
we've all been waiting for
well morning must-see TV it's up there
with the Dallas episode right where we
had a way to no license I have to be up
yes it'll be definitely nice to see
everybody got to get up and watch I mean
you can't miss it but you know we
already know the top-line conclusion
okay there was no collusion matter of
fact there was no effort occlusion and
the Russians tried to collude and the
Trump team said no my question now going
forward is what the heck was Bob Muller
doing for 675 days Andy McCarthy has an
absolutely terrific piece where he asked
this question how quickly did Muller
figure out there was no collusion the
bureau been up on a wire for a year and
a half they had it know nothing was
going on what was he doing for 617
question just going back to a previous
Special Counsel investigation which is
that Patrick Fitzgerald the US Attorney
who was a special counsel for the
Valerie Plame case knew immediately who
had leaked the name and it wasn't Karl
Rove and that still went on for four
more years they're doing they like that
Murray you're gonna be up ready I'm
ready out wait but do you think they
don't know what's in it heat now I do
think it's a good thing that he's going
to take questions from the press and
that might take a little bit of the
tension oil out of it we'll see right I
think that some of what Dan said Barr
did not say was in the Muller report he
did not say there was no that the Trump
campaign said no thank you when they
tried to collude so I think one of the
things that people are looking for is
how Muller explains themes and events we
know happened and how he explains that
they do not amount to criminal collusion
just as an American and as a human I
actually want to see how Muller deals
with the Trump Tower meeting manna for
giving polling to the Russians all of
those things I do think the president
Trump's tweets about the Muller report
have gotten increasingly how do I say
this nicely aggressive and
the past few days like he it seems a
little bit like he's he's trying to
preempt what he knows will not be a
uniformly good report for him there will
be things in this report that are
embarrassing that all of us sitting
around this table would say I would
never have done that if I had worked on
a presidential campaign I think Trump
knows that is trying to get ahead of it
or do you think Jesse that maybe he is
just I don't know if it's any more
aggressive than before a year and a half
I think anything's changed there past
few days though filled a little
different does it feel different for you
well I'm glad you're in touch with your
feelings Marie I think 9:30 is a little
early I would have preferred 10:30 or
11:00 and it given me more time to go to
the gym and digest I also I also think
this is what's gonna happen when the
report comes out okay a bunch of liberal
media members are gonna hold up each
page and they're gonna hold it into the
sunlight to see if they could see behind
the redaction because everybody does
that I always do that and there's a
small hope I can and you're not going to
be able to do that I think what he
should do just to mess with the press is
give 400 pages of the whole thing
redacted just to screw up screw around
with them and then say fine here's the
real important big black just one big
crazy but I I think you're right there
is going to be some derogatory
information in there because this was a
very brutally intrusive exam and do an
administration in the campaign so you're
gonna find some flaws and this was
undertaken by kind of ferocious and that
sinister but angry partisan Democrats
with a lot of liberal pedigree so
they're gonna find some things but
overall no obstruction no collusion I
just don't know how CNN is going to
handle it because this last week they
had the lowest rated week of all of 2019
so they have a choice to make are they
going to now report real news about
Spygate are they going to continue to
push fake news because they lost to the
Food Network last week which means
people would rather watch a pot boil
than watch CNN you like these things
happen you'd like to get the news but
you also like to watch the other media
getting the news yeah yes you know what
this reminds me of do you remember April
the giraffe yeah do you remember how
long we
waited this is like April to the giraffe
having twins at separate times it's like
okay April already give us the giraffe
three weeks ago anyway
this the media are like movie critics
who are denying the spoilers right
there's like we know what he know what
happened but there didn't oh no I looka
a Darth Vader really isn't his father no
it is sorry guys but you know what it is
the molar report to the media is like
cheap tequila in high school you try it
you get drunk and you have a hangover
forever but then you forget about it and
you do it again so they're setting
themselves up for feeling miserable on
Thursday afternoon I will agree with you
Murray and once there is this prison of
two ideas he's vindicated or it's a
cover-up there's gonna be a lot of
little things going on that people can
sink their teeth into they're gonna say
whoa now we know that the Russians
colluded but we also know that that it
was a one-way street the trumps weren't
chasing it and so you go you it just
means you have to be more aware of what
the Russians are doing but we already
knew that it's really about the Russians
and how they manipulated the media not
the voters the collusion was the it was
the meet and Russia playing the media
for suckers Dana can I add something
here that is it's interesting how the
standard is shifted here though into
there's gonna be negative information
okay the whole July 5th Jim called me
press conference was negative
information about Hillary yet everybody
wanted to make that go away but you're
right if you were there for basically a
proctology exam on your entire life for
the last five years of course there's
going to be negative if I've been there
but that's not thankfully but that is
not the question the question here is
was a crime committed and the answer
according to bar summary is no collusion
but on obstruction we know that Bob
Muller is going to lay out a legal case
for obstruction and a legal case that
says it doesn't Bryce the level of
obstruction he didn't answer
why did he charge his job is the charge
on charges guys I think Muller should
have made a decision on that I agree
with you he should have made a decision
and not left it up to bar but there will
be an entire section that says this is
why we believe Donald Trump committed
obstruction so when you say no
something you didn't do bar said that's
actually not true legally obstruction
you can be charged with even if there's
no underlying crime so you framed me for
murder and I say stop obstructing the
bar that's not exactly the legal
standard but bar says it's an analogy
bar said that Muller laid out a case for
obstruction and against obstruction and
then bar made the decision so there will
be a case for obstruction in what I see
tomorrow yes dan one other question
which is that the Attorney General opt
is definitely going to get additional
questions about what the the verb he
used last week in congressional
testimony which was he believed there
was spying on the Trump campaign and so
I don't know if the mole report goes
into that fully but certainly if you
open yourself up to a press conference
you're gonna get questions about it well
no sane person believes that the team
wasn't spied on not only they use
national security read letters on the
record not only do we now know that was
a human intelligence asset used against
the Trump team on the record we also
know that a Foreign Intelligence
Surveillance Court a synonym for spying
for rational people they used a warrant
and three renewals to spy on the Trump
team getting into the euphemism game is
the height of political immaturity just
take the El you spied on the Trump team
admit it drop the Lost Democrats and cut
the euphemism crap it looks silly
you didn't spy you employed a spot no he
was an undocumented informant like crazy
like every sane person knows the guy was
a spy but then no matter what Jesse the
congressional Democrats now remember
Alexandria Castillo Cortez she said
she's for impeachment just last week she
said that Pelosi said well like we're
not there yet but do you think that
tomorrow at 9:31 a.m. the Democrats will
say they have a case well they'd have to
be pretty fast readers to do that but
I'm sure they're gonna try to make some
sort of hay out of it just but going
back to your point think about how the
spine happened they cooked up the
intelligence leaked it to the press and
took the fake news reports and use it to
get a wire to spy and I can tell you now
we know that it's true the Trump
campaign and all our official their
officials they are not as nervous as the
Obama officials because they know that
this are starting to spin against them
now I look very calm right now - I do
have kind of an ocular migraine and I'd
like to blame that on John Rich or
forcing me to drink whiskey and say ten
I cannot see out of my left eye so it's
anybody who has ocular migraines no one
I'm talking about you feel like you're
the Terminator figure out what the cause
of your ocular migraines I thought the
people could sunshine and whisky